I was so calm for I wanted the use of
themes to be a little more cinematic a
little more sophisticated and I thought
about the the big picture in the
narrative and really socom four is a
much more narrative experience in any
previous silicon games and there are
variations of these themes that you hear
that comment on the bigger picture what
is the main character thinking about at
this chapter in the story there are
times when he knows he's doing the right
thing he's feeling triumphant and
excited and there's no question in his
mind but there are other places where
there's a little moral gray area is he
doing the right thing the theme sounds
differently there I'm not just
commenting on the guys shooting at you
trying to kill you I'm also on a
subconscious level trying to get the
gamer to remember well this is what the
characters feeling at this general stage
in the story or there are times when I'm
hinting at things that are going to come
later and all of it is background
because ostensibly I'm creating suspense
music while someone's trying to kill you
the thing that drives me the most crazy
about video game soundtracks is
repetition games last for a long time
they can be replayed it's it's
incredibly important that you don't hear
the same music over and over again so
that your brain isn't categorizing this
is something that's safe and familiar
you're you're on the edge of your seat
and and I I think subconsciously not
even knowing why you don't notice that
the scary music is going away which
means that you've you're exiting a
danger zone you just feel a score for
what you're experiencing so you can
think of the music score as you know a
timeline if you will the certain layers
deep that hold different types of
intensity different types of music based
on who the players fighting or what
state he's in that sort of thing and the
vertical markers that determine where
music can come in where it can go out it
was almost as if the game was scoring in
real time as he played I remember back
in the Commodore 64 days Eve even now
there's a contingent of you know sort of
like retro musicians who use the SID
chip and they no good for that 8-bit
stuff and there wasn't there they were
even back in the day there were amazing
musicians who just eat out just every
time you thought you'd heard you know
that the limits of what game game audio
chips could could manage they'd make
something amazing but they were rare and
often they were like very you know
treasured Jim within the game
more often what you heard from bleeps
and bloops one of my favorite games ever
is a game called elite is the seminal
space trading game back in the day the
grandfather of all you know space
trading games and and one of the
interesting aspects of that game was it
was entirely silent it was devoid of
music except when you turned your
docking computers on and I played the
Blue Danube similar 2001 the docking
sequence and I remember just being
amazed at at the complexity of that
piece in relation to the other spectrum
Commodore 64 music I was hearing which
was you know mostly junk I think now
we're realizing that just like our in
our bigger brothers in the theater and
film that is something to we just can't
ignore you know and and have a triple a
product it's a part of the package
you